[Music]
richard feynman was worried
about a number
in the 1940s he had worked out how
electrons interact with light an insight
that earned him a nobel prize but a
particular number bothered him
all good theoretical physicists put this
number up on their wall and worry about
it
immediately you would like to know where
this number comes from
nobody knows it's one of the greatest
damn mysteries of physics a magic number
that comes to us with no understanding
by man
that number
was the fine structure constant
it sits at the heart of feynman's
theoretical success quantum
electrodynamics it is a number that
tells us about the strength of
electromagnetism and has a value close
to one divided by 137
feynman's theory cannot calculate this
number and his equations are impotent
until you measure its value in an
experiment
and scientists today are still asking
the same question that feynman did 70
years
ago where does
this number
come from
and it is not alone
our physical theories are awash with
constants of nature
they dictate how the fundamental pieces
of the universe operate how electrons
repel electrons and how gravity draws
matter together some of these constants
are familiar such as the speed of light
and planks constant others such as quark
mixing and yukawa couplings are found
within the complicated mathematics of
physics on the edge and without
measuring and calibrating these numbers
all physical theories would be useless
the constants of nature are clearly
central to all physics
but they appear to play a pivotal role
in an even bigger question
how
are we
here to understand this we are going to
have to take a journey
into ourselves
peeling apart a human we find a complex
mix of organs and fluids as we appear
closer we find that these are built from
a diverse range of individual cells each
interacting to perform the task of the
liver or muscle or the brain closer
still each cell is revealed to be a sea
of complexity a wealth of smaller
elements ribosomes and chromosomes
cytoplasm and mitochondria each playing
a part in the running of the cell the
pieces of these cells are composed of
molecules proteins and lipids dna and
rna each level so far has uncovered a
wealth of complexity but as we go
further simplicity appears molecules are
built from atoms with each complex
arrangement enabling the complex
interactions with others but chemistry
tells us that there are only 92 natural
elements from hydrogen to uranium
so only 92 different kinds of atoms are
available
entering the world of the subatomic and
even simpler picture is uncovered with
each atom being a mix of three different
particles protons and neutrons within
the atomic nucleus with orbiting
electrons and the protons and neutrons
are also composed of smaller particles
known as up and down quarks here at this
fundamental level we find that matter
people trees planets and stars are
nothing but different arrangements of
these quarks and electrons
of course these pieces need glue to hold
them together and for fundamental
particles this is provided by the
fundamental forces atomic nuclei are
held together by the strong force atoms
hold on to electrons with the
electromagnetic force gravity draws
matter together to form planets and
stars in the mix also is the weak force
which can influence the stability of
atoms
simply put we are built from the ground
up
our physical existence in this universe
is nothing more than the manifestation
of a huge number of interactions of its
fundamental pieces
and all these interactions are dictated
by the values
of the constants
of nature
but where did these values come from
does the cosmos
have to be this way
and was the fundamental universe primed
from the big bang to now to necessarily
produce the complexity that appears to
be essential
for life
these seem like strange questions
we have only this universe with the
values of these constants of nature
revealed to us by experiment
they appear to be written into the very
fabric of existence
but science is built on what-if games
pondering how things would change if the
situation were different
what if questions have the potential to
answer not only the question of how we
are here
but maybe
even why
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
question at the speed of light how long
would it take to travel to andromeda our
nearest galaxy a 500 years b 2.5 million
years or c
25 million years
that's right it's 2.5 million years and
infinite energy
probably not worth it
and so our recommendation this week is
the documentary faster than light the
dream of interstellar flight a
fascinating exploration of the different
possibilities when it comes to venturing
towards our nearest neighbours
antimatter drives warp speed laser
engines explore the wild edges of
theoretical science magellan are a sort
of netflix for documentaries with more
than 3 000 documentaries to choose from
on a wide range of topics
so click on the link in the description
for an exclusive month-long free trial
for history of the universe viewers
thanks
standing here on earth it is easy to
think that the universe was made for us
it feels like we are at the center of
everything with the sun and the stars
whirling around us
indeed as human civilization began our
cosmic location was written into our
developing religions
to the ancient babylonians our flat
circular earth was surrounded by an
infinite ocean of chaos
the greeks and romans saw the patterns
in the stars as a storyboard of myths
and legends of gods and monsters
in china the universe was arranged in
rotating shells centered on the earth
and containing the stars and planets
but science has since stripped away this
illusion in 1543 the astronomer and
mathematician nicolaus copernicus
displaced the earth placing the sun at
the center of everything the dethroned
earth orbited this fiery heart of the
universe
the coming of the 20th century saw us
demoted further as massive telescopes
peered into the heavens it became clear
that the sun is but one of billions of
other stars within our milky way galaxy
and now we know the milky way is one of
potentially trillions of galaxies in the
observable universe
whilst hubble charted the cosmos
measuring immense distances between the
galaxies einstein friedman and lametra
found it to be evolving and expanding
born in an event 14 billion years ago we
now call the big bang
but where
does that leave us
one possible answer came from the ever
insightful douglas adams who wrote in
his comic novel hitchhiker's guide to
the galaxy
far out in the uncharted backwaters of
the unfashionable end of the western
spiral arm of the galaxy lies a small
unregarded yellow sun orbiting this at a
distance of roughly 92 million miles is
an utterly insignificant little
blue-green planet whose ape-descended
life forms are so amazingly primitive
that they still think digital watches
are a pretty neat idea
but far from just a punchline our
irrelevance in the cosmic scheme of
things has become a central tenet of
science
dubbed the copernican principle we have
developed our scientific theories based
on the idea that we are nowhere special
the view from the earth is essentially
the same as from any other vantage point
in the immense universe
we are little more than cosmological
bystanders
[Music]
or are we
in the 1960s princeton astronomer robert
dickey was seeking to understand the
origin of the universe
he was a polymath making important
discoveries in atomic physics and
einstein's general relativity
born from his thoughts on the birth of
the universe dickey had been thinking
about our cosmic location not in terms
of space
but in terms of time
he realized that living thinking beings
like us cannot exist at any random time
in the life of the universe
in the first couple of billion years the
universe was devoid of carbon oxygen and
other heavy elements as these were still
deep inside the first cosmic generation
of stars until these stars died the raw
material for complexity and life was
absent
and 100 billion years into the future
all stars like the sun would have died
and become white dwarfs the dominant
stars in the universe would be the puny
red dwarfs faint little stars whose
prospects for habitability are small
so he realized that there was a window
of time between the early and late
universe where life could thrive
a golden age of habitability
and of course we should not be surprised
to find ourselves living during this
time of cosmic history
we are not observing the universe at a
random point in its immense lifetime
decay posited but during a period that
allows us to be here
whilst this may not feel particularly
insightful it does shake the foundations
of the copernican principle a little
the situation became more complicated in
1973
at a conference held in krakow poland to
celebrate the 500th birthday of
copernicus australian physicist brandon
carter gave a speech
and he had copernicus squarely in his
sights
for humans observing the universe he
said
although our situation is not
necessarily central it is inevitably
privileged to some extent
for us to be here generations of stars
living over billions of years are
required to turn hydrogen into the
heavier elements essential for our
existence but carter went further
the lifespan of a star is determined by
the physical processes in its heart
gravity squeezes the stellar core
driving it to immense densities and
pressures in this environment new
elements are forged with the rate of
nuclear cooking determined by the other
fundamental forces electromagnetism and
the strong and weak nuclear forces
these elements forged in stars include
the iron in the earth's core and the
silicon in its crust it includes the
oxygen in the water of our oceans and
the carbon that is the basis for all
life on the planet
and so carter first coined a new concept
in contrast to the copernican principle
the anthropic principle
was born
our very existence some 14 billion years
after the birth of the universe is
because of the extremely delicate
balance of the fundamental forces that
govern the life cycles of stars
and so
taking all of this into account we are
left with a question
if
we are so privileged
what would happen
if that
were to change
what if gravity were a little stronger
or electromagnetism
a little weaker
what
if the rules of the universe
were different
in 1900 max planck was desperate
he had been struggling to understand how
objects glowed as you heated them from
red to white hot
like others he had been trying to use
the theory of light written into james
clark maxwell's theory of
electromagnetism
and
like the others he had failed
in his desperation he threw out the
classical ideas of heat and energy
thinking he had introduced little more
than a mathematical trick planck had
unknowingly invented quantum mechanics
but this trick this quantization worked
and planck would win the nobel prize in
1918 for his insight
nestled in his equation was a number
central to his result
today we call this number planck's
constant in honor of its discoverer and
this number now has a central role in
quantum physics explaining not only how
hot objects glow but atomic structure
the interaction of matter and light and
a myriad of strange quantum effects
it is a constant of nature
and these numbers are essential for
studying hypothetical other universes
[Music]
physics is written in the language of
mathematics
and through mathematical equations we
make predictions on how objects behave
when we want to understand the motion of
the moon we can combine newton's laws of
motion and gravity to predict where the
moon will be tomorrow or in a week or in
a thousand years
when we want to understand the flow of
electricity we can use maxwell's
equations of electromagnetism and the
properties of electrons to deduce the
expected reading on an amateur but the
equations of physics are not purely
mathematical you cannot determine how
things evolve from mathematical
manipulation alone there is another
vital ingredient that has to be added
the values of the constants of nature in
newton's theory of gravity there is the
gravitational constant and without
knowing its value the equations are
sterile in electromagnetism there are
the permeabilities and permittivities of
electricity and magnetism without
knowing their values maxwell's equations
are muted and to determine the value of
these constants scientists must ask
nature
they have to measure them
the year is 1798 and henry cavendish is
about to run his experiment
one more time
he places his eye to the telescope which
is not faced towards the heavens
but through brick poking through a small
hole in the wall of a shed in his garden
so as not to interrupt the incredibly
delicate apparatus he has placed it
inside a wooden box within the shed
protecting it from wind and the outside
world the equipment itself measures the
strength of gravity between lead balls
using an incredibly sensitive torsion
balance and with it cavendish was able
to measure the density of the entire
earth
weighing the world as he called it a
result which led directly to the
calculation of the gravitational
constant with accuracy not exceeded for
another hundred years
and this quest for exactness continues
to this very day with the constant g
known to six decimal places
and it's not just gravity measurements
for the speed of light which is the
ultimate constant for electromagnetism
and plonk's constant have been refined
over decades they are joined by more
esoteric values such as the strength of
the higgs field and the mixing angles of
quarks
as well as the constants of nature there
are other values of the universe that
cannot be deduced solely from
mathematics and so must be discovered
these include the masses of the
fundamental particles such as the quarks
and electrons that comprise all of
matter
these values are in fact so important
that physics textbooks tabulate them so
readers can use the equations of physics
between the covers
of course the constants tend to have
units and so changing from meters and
kilograms to feet and pounds will mean
that the value of the constants will
change
so scientists focus upon combinations of
the constants that are dimensionless a
proton for example is
1836 times heavier than an electron if
the masses are measured in kilograms
pounds or troy ounces
but why 1836
why do the constants have the particular
values they do
how would the universe have been
different if this ratio had been 18 or
18 000
and so we return to the fine structure
constant
why is it one divided by 137
theoretically these are questions we can
start to answer we can solve our
equations of physics when considering
different values for the fundamental
constants with this we can calculate
what would happen in the hypothetical
universe if gravity was a thousand times
stronger than in our universe gripping
the earth more tightly in the sun's grip
making us orbit more rapidly but this is
not quite what we are searching for
if we want to know how the universe
would have turned out if the constants
of nature had been different we must
consider the evolutionary history of the
cosmos with a different strength of
gravity or electromagnetism or heavier
electrons or some other mix of different
physics
we have to go back
to the beginning
naively we may think that this might
change the time period when complexity
and life could have arisen in the
universe if gravity was increased that
would increase the rate at which nuclear
reactions could happen meaning heavier
elements and hence life could have
appeared earlier in the universe
but this
as scientists have discovered
is thinking far
far too small
[Music]
astronomers have had great success in
explaining our universe playing
by the rules
around the globe teams of scientists are
building their own synthetic universes
translating the equations of cosmology
and astrophysics into computer code
with the aid of supercomputers they can
trace the complex interplay of matter
and radiation in an expanding universe
as computer power has grown so has the
scale of the synthetic universes with
projects such as the illustrious tng or
the next generation tracing the cosmic
evolution of a cubic chunk of synthetic
universe a billion light years on a side
over the billions of years within these
synthetic universes cosmic expansion
acts to pull mata further apart while
gravity acts to draw it together mass
clumps into proto-galaxies whilst the
computers solve the equations for the
flow of gas and the formation of stars
within these synthetic universes stars
live out their lives some exploding
spectacularly as supernovae whilst
others expire with a final puff
all the while the computer programs are
tracking the formation and dispersal of
elements as generations of stars come
and go
an inspection of these synthetic
universes reveals rich structure with
synthetic galaxies and clusters clouds
of pure gas left over from the big bang
and other clouds polluted with heavier
elements
these synthetic universes look just like
ours a confirmation that the universe we
see around us is imprinted and shaped by
the physics underlying the cosmos
and the same is true for our existence
the presence of complex molecules
composed of atoms is also a
manifestation of this physics of the
fundamental the result of stars being
able to undergo nuclear burning at their
cores
of course if we can generate a synthetic
universe on a computer or even with
paper and pencil for the physics of our
universe it seems that it should be
simple to think of different physics in
hypothetical universes all we need to do
is to change the numerical values of the
constants of nature maybe we just tweak
our computer code press go and see how
early or how late life arises or how
many arms or legs we end up with
but is it really
that straightforward
we are the result of a complex web of
physical interactions over the billions
of years of the life of the cosmos and
to truly answer the question of
habitability we must understand how
cutting the web or even forging new
pathways
impacts the existence of the complexity
needed for life
a limited view might come from
simplified cases but to truly capture
the complexity scientists turn to the
power of supercomputers to churn through
interweaved equations
they are still unraveling the
habitability of other universes
but as they survey the multiverse of
possibilities
the view
is a grim one
calculations reveal a vast ocean
of darkness
and death
almost every other possible universe
appears to be lifeless
and sterile
in many universes there is no structure
no galaxies stars and planets in others
no complexity no periodic table of
elements dotted among the dead universes
there are little islands of complexity
and potentially life
but these
are almost vanishingly rare
let's consider some examples of what
happens when you play
with the constants of nature
[Music]
in our universe the relative masses of
the fundamental up and down quarks mean
that the proton is lighter than the
neutron
this means that neutrons decay into
protons and so just after the big bang
the cosmos was awash with protons these
protons are the hearts of every hydrogen
atom providing the universe the
potential to form stars and heavier
elements
ultimately this endowed our universe
with the potential to create us
messing with the masses of the quarks
can have a radical effect if the down
quark was lighter the neutron would be
less massive than the proton in such a
universe the big bang would have
resulted in a sea of inert neutrons
stars of neutrons would form but no
nuclear fires would burn in this
universe there would be no periodic
table of elements there would be no
complexity
there would be
no life
instead of quarks we could consider the
mass of the electron zipping around the
nucleus these dictate the world of
chemistry of how mata can join into
molecules and crystals in our universe
the nuclear force is thousands of times
more massive than the electron but if
the electron were more massive its high
speed orbit would cause the nucleus to
rattle around in response this rattling
would impact the ability of atoms to
bond together and there becomes a point
where nothing but individual atoms could
exist
everything would be a gas
with no molecules
and no solids the prospects for life
are bleak
and a universe with a different force of
gravity is equally dramatic if not more
so firstly it is gravity that is
responsible for drawing mata together in
the early universe forming the first
stars and galaxies if gravity was too
weak then the expanding universe would
have remained an ever-thinning soup of
hydrogen gas if gravity were too strong
then mata would be quickly drawn into
numerous black holes locking away the
atomic material needed for life
and even between these two extremes
gravity plays a pivotal role
the lives of stars are dictated by the
influence of gravity squeezing the
stellar core to the point where nuclear
reactions can ignite
squeezing too weakly will result in
stars being nothing more than immense
balls of cooling gas
squeezing too hard means that the
nuclear reactor would kick into
overdrive burning through the available
material in much less than the 10
billion year lifetime of stars like the
sun
long-lived stable stars appear to walk a
knife edge when it comes to the strength
of gravity
and finally even changing the values of
things that we've only just discovered
would have an enormous impact on
habitability
in our universe today dark energy is the
dominant component and is driving the
expansion faster and faster in the early
universe mata dominated steadily slowing
expansion until dark energy took over
roughly 5 billion years ago this slowing
expansion in the early universe gave
gravity the time to draw mata into stars
and galaxies in the distant future dark
energy will dilute the universe to such
an extent that each galaxy will appear
alone in the darkness
but if there were more dark energy in
the universe it would have dominated
earlier it could have started its
accelerated expansion a lot earlier
before mata had the chance to collapse
into the first stars in such a universe
individual hydrogen atoms would find
themselves alone
in cold empty space the prospects for
life would have been negligible
and there are many more components of
the universe we could consider such as
the speed of light the scalar of quantum
mechanics or the stability of dark
matter for some of these the range over
which complexity and habitability
results can be relatively large but for
others a percentage change here or there
can have a dramatic impact
consideration of each aspect of physics
rules out a chunk of hypothetical
universes that could ever host life
in this sea of potential universes
ours is the exception
not the rule
in this sea of potential universes
we
are effectively
alone
and so we have answered the first
question
how are we here
we are the result of an almost perfectly
balanced selection of rules interacting
over 13.8 billion years
but now the second question rears its
head
why
[Music]
the constants of nature have always had
a mystical aura to some physicists
there must they feel be some reason for
their particular values
some have even turned to numerology
siratha eddington astronomer at the
university of cambridge and the first
person to conduct an experiment to
verify einstein's general theory of
relativity fell into this trap
like feynman he was consumed by the fine
structure constant thinking that it
might be exactly 1 over 137
he concluded that this value was related
to the total number of protons in the
observable universe but as measurements
of the fine structure constant became
more accurate it was realized that it
was not one divided by an integral value
and eddington's idea was quietly dropped
but the connections between the
constants of nature might be telling us
something deeper
as our scientific theories advance and
disparate pieces are united as one the
number of these constants needed to
describe the universe decreases
before maxwell two separate constants
were needed one to describe the action
of electric phenomena and another to
describe magnetism within maxwell's
equations these two numbers were united
into a single constant of nature
the speed of light
and so is this the answer if physicists
work hard enough to produce a theory of
everything will all of fundamental
physics be unified no constants left
just pure mathematics the notion of this
ultimate theory is currently a moonshot
idea in physics and it might not exist
but the moment's thought also reveals
that this would not really provide us
with an answer we would just change the
question
why then would these mathematical
expressions
allow us to be here
it offers us nothing but another vast
graveyard of dead alternate universes
with no explanation
and the question would still remain why
is the physics just right enough
for us to be here
to some this fine tuning of the physical
properties of our universe is because
there is a fine tuner a divine being
that made the universe for us
of course this fits neatly with a lot of
religious ideas around the globe and the
fine-tuning argument is often taken as
evidence for the existence of at least
one god
but there is an alternate idea
university of oxford philosopher nick
bostrom has noted that we understand the
universe by simulating pieces of it on a
computer in the future when computers
become more powerful we will be able to
simulate more of the complexities of the
universe to finer detail perhaps our
computers will grow so powerful that
conscious beings will be part of the
program and maybe these beings will
happily exist in their universe without
realizing their reality is nothing but a
simulation
and maybe in the future we won't just
simulate one universe but a variety of
universes each with differing laws of
physics and properties of course we will
not simulate boring universes where
nothing happens
no we will focus our resources on
interesting universes with interesting
things
like life
and bostrom takes this idea of simulated
universes one step further
and wonders if it has already happened
not inside our universe but with our
universe being simulated within someone
else's
our laws of physics are nothing but
executing computer code
so our thoughts and experiences of
reality
so we should not be surprised to find
ourselves in such universe
as the great programmer in the sky above
is expending their computational
resources on us
an interesting
simulation this idea is loved by
philosophers but scientists not so much
what can we do with this concept how do
we test we are in a simulation if all we
do is express computer code as the laws
of physics
and of course there is the problem of
whether the universe above is a
simulation also
and we are left with turtles
all the way up
but there is one more idea that science
has posited
what if all these possible universes
are not hypothetical
what if they are real distinct universes
out there in a real
multiverse
we don't yet have a definitive theory of
a multiverse it is more of a collection
of disparate ideas but perhaps within
the multiverse there is a process that
generates individual universes each
universe born with its own distinct set
of physical laws selected at random by
some role of the metaphorical dice even
our own universe if started again could
have been born with different physical
laws
of course in the multiverse picture most
of the individual universes are dead and
sterile
in this picture we were lucky we got
that roll of the dice that allows us to
be here
the concept of the multiverse is not
universally loved among cosmologists
with declarations that it is extremely
wasteful to have all these dead
universes so ours could live others
point out that the multiverse is not
really a theory as there is no
mathematics to back it up or predictions
we could test as those other universes
will always remain disconnected from us
and so the question remains
the whims of gods computer simulations
or multiverses
perhaps one of these will eventually
give us an answer
or something stranger
still
but before that time considering both
the how and why of our existence
still has a lot to tell us about the
universe
and our place in it
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
and we'll see you
next time
[Music]